hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm we just wrapped up to
the 2015 sink Feld cup congratulations
to Levon Aronian who walks away with the
victory did not honestly expect him to
do so well he went undefeated he won
three games and tied 6 so he ended up
with 6 points a lot of people tied for
second place with five points to those
individuals Magnus Carlsen and Nakamura
I thought both had a legitimate chance
to actually win this tournament so
congratulations to all the competitors
been really fun tournament to cover
we've had a lot of videos on YouTube as
well as on the site as well so if you
haven't checked all those make sure you
check them out but thought i'd be pretty
cool to go over the match of the
tournament by a long shot super exciting
match today if you have not seen before
it's between Wesley so and Nakamura from
round six two Americans facing off and
this kind of a heavyweight boxing match
where sometimes you see some matches and
it's kind of a one guy kind of hanging
back doesn't want to get punched very
much this is just a all-out brawl both
sides throwing everything they have at
their opponents just trying to go all
out at the end the day we just want to
see who's left standing and that's
exactly what we see so if you're not too
familiar with it you're definitely going
to enjoy we're going to get started
Wesley so starts out with pawn to d4
Knight f6 poncy for pongee 693 Mishra to
g7 and then after pawn to e4 we go pawn
to d6 so this is the Kings Indian
defense which typically is more of a
passive defense Nakamura I was kind of
expecting this a hyper modern defense oh
he's not really looking to control the
center of the board right away instead
looking to control the center with his
minor pieces maybe later on
counter-attack by pushing forward but
pawn here to be five maybe if he wants
to counter-attack on the queenside pawn
here to see five he has some options
here but it's kind of more of a quiet
move you cast on the kingside get King
side safety there's usually not a lot of
threats on board so as we kind of
started didn't look like anything was
going to happen but we definitely saw
fireworks later on so continues with
nine f3 castle on the kingside bishop
here to eat ooh pawn to e5 as we talked
about castle in the King side so
everything
looks normal so far knight c6 pawn to d5
and I back here to e7 both sides of
simple development moves nothing too
crazy is going on so far night back here
to e2 that signifies that usually why
it's going to be a little bit more
aggressive start pushing forward with
this pawn right here because this night
is fine position right here can get his
dark squared Bishop involvement of the
game [ __ ] beard to g5 can always start
attacking on the key or the queenside
pawn 284 start pushing on that side but
knight to e 1 somewhat kind of looks
like he's going to attack on the King
side pushing his pawn forward a knight
back here to d7 in pond to f3 and this
is kind of what we see in the game we
didn't have to see this I kind of
expected just for y to try to dominate
on the queenside but after pawn here to
f3 we see pawn to f5 so you can tell
right away that Nakamura is not looking
to play a safe game usually when you
feeling kettle your Bishop to one side
of the board you usually don't start to
push your pawns especially this early on
into the game so now Bishop e2 e3 so so
saying okay you're going to attack on
the King side i'm gonna go ahead and
start lining up all my pieces to attack
on the queen set i'm going to try to
overwhelm me on the queenside and then
just barage your king with attacks once
i have completely decimated your queen
set up on here to f4 bishop comes back
here to f2 making sure still attacking
over here on the queenside pawn to g5 it
if you actually analyze this position on
board through an engine if you're kind
of watching it may be through trash 24
they did live commentary you can
actually see the engines analyzing this
it was showing why ahead by a longshot
it's at about two points which really
that equates either two ponds if you're
just looking at equal sides of the board
with ponds off but really it just comes
down to whites in a pretty dominant
position usually if you're up by two
points you're going to go on to win
previously knock more has other plans
though he's going to just try to be
super aggressive and see if he can just
overwhelm his opponents so pawn to g5 no
regard for King side safety that's okay
at night here to d3 night over here to
g6 pawn pushing to c5 so is going to go
ahead and continue with his plan on the
queenside he has a
huge majority over here his pawns are
kind of facing that way so that's kind
of where he's looking to go it's going
to be very easy for him to overwhelm
nakamura on the queenside not over here
to f6 rook to see one just getting ready
to even push further add more pressure
on that side rook here to f7 King over
here to h1 I don't think there's much
game by Wesley's no playing King to h1
he's not really under pressure right now
I think pry makes more sense to just
continue to be aggressive pawn to 8 a-4
just keep pushing for just try to
overwhelm iskcon his opponent even more
but King to h1 not a terrible move pawn
to age 5 we can all kind of assume that
knock mores just going gangbusters over
here not trying to do anything except
throw everything at his opponent so
that's what you continues do pawn here
to d6 capture or recapture here night
here to be five I don't know that white
necessarily needs to play this night to
be five game he's attacking the pawn
here on d6 but there's not too much
thread after pawn to a6 the night comes
back here to a three I didn't even think
coming back here to see three makes
sense night 2 a 3 yes if you want to
come back to c4 and then attack if you
even if you want to come up here to be
six but that's a lot of moves with so
much going on the kingside the board you
just don't really have all that much
time tonight on a three it's just going
to be sitting there for a while pawn
here to be five just kind of stopping a
lot of those threats so just kind of
hanging out here this is most the reason
why I just don't like this at night here
to a3 move but now the risk is come up
here to see six so Wesley so say hey I'm
just gonna I'm gonna get all up in your
business over here and it's gonna be
very difficult for you to do anything
nakamura says i don't care at all i'm
just going to keep throwing stuff at the
King side and just let's see if
something cool happens so pawn here to
g4 queen here to see to Quinn over here
to f8 sand knock more just lining
everything up a rook here to see one so
says i don't care i'm going to line
everything up on the queenside and we're
just going to have a battle here Bishop
here to d7 rook here to see seven
getting it on that seventh-ranked
definitely important for both sides of
the control that seventh rank because
knock more is going to be in huge
trouble if he just allows upon
to kind of overwhelm him art here on the
7th right Bishop coming back here to e1
so starting to recognize that he needs
to change a little bit up as far as
defense also wants to kind of maneuver
as Bishop to do a little bit more than
it was doing upon here to age for knock
more continues to push forward now we do
start to see a break open so the pawn
takes here on g4 and the pond pushing
forward just lightly let's just continue
to break step up pawn to f3 so now
they're start to get a little space in
front of this King right here on h1 now
we see a sacrifice so night taking here
on e4 and then work over here to d1 this
work on d1 is not doing anything at all
it just not doing anything productive
whatsoever I really don't know what
Wesley so is doing if he's just not sure
of the pressure that's going on but work
here daddy Wanda seems very very poor to
me now we see a rook sacrifice rook down
here taking on f3 rook taking here on d7
does not want to just take right away
there's problems with that as well but
rook taking on these seven now the work
comes down here to f1 we see the King
come up here to g2 now the bishop comes
here to e3 and this is kind of really
really bad you know if we come back in
the the bishop takes or something the
Queen's just going to come down this is
checkmate so that there's a lot of moves
that white can play he actually plays
pretty well in all these positions even
though he is already in tons of trouble
but King here to g2 Bishop here to e3
and this is this is a dagger that you
just have a hard time getting out of
there's no real great move here so plays
Bishop here to g3 which actually looks
kind of awkward us are you just giving
up a pawn there but really what option
does he have he could play because if
the threat is rook here to g1 if you're
kind of wondering what Nakamura is
trying to do if you kind of block it
with Bishop here to f2 well then just
rook takes then if the night takes the
Queen comes down and then all of a
sudden Bishop here to f4 is just
completely deadly that's really bad if
we come back and say ok let's just go
ahead and block it off with let's say
the night here to f2 then rook takes
Bishop takes now pawn to h3
is a pretty deadly move and then King
back here to H 1 night 2 F to check
that's very bad if the King were to take
a lot of different options but getting
the Queen involvement of the game check
that's going to be very bad not a lot of
options for white as well there so we
come back it's not great but Bishop here
to g3 the move we saw pawn takes here
this pond is now protected by this night
here on e four so all these pieces
really start to work together now the
rook takes over here on f1 all you can
really do is start to take material and
hope for the best now night here to h4
check King up here to h3 now Queen to h6
just so many threats there's not much
that why can really do here upon up here
to g5 sure Knight takes here all these
pieces are really protected really
really well king here to g4 night here
to f3 these nights are protecting each
other this Bishop is protecting this
night as well you know the king could
take this pawn if he wants to but then
just the Queen down here would be
checkmate so that's going to be bad
definitely don't want to do that we see
night to f2 King down here to h4 the
King's gonna come up here at any time
you know Wesley so he could just tip his
King over he recognizes that he's
probably in a losing situation there's
no way he can kind of get out of this
was really nice to actually see him play
on such a beautiful in game from
nakamura all these different sacrifices
to get his opponent's king hall the way
marching up the board so really good to
actually see sportsmanship of his you
know fellow American actually playing
this game out but work over here to f8
wants to make sure you get all his
pieces involved in the game King up here
to g6 rook down here to f6 hey why not
an extra sacrifice at the end of the
game that rook wasn't doing anything so
let's just go ahead and sacrifice them
to the king here now night here to e4
check and then after king here then we
see Queen up here to g5 checkmate you
just never see checkmates very often so
you know was really cool to actually see
this so fantastic game just so much
craziness going on really enjoyed this
wasn't expecting it at all so hopefully
you guys enjoyed this game something
rare that we see hopefully you enjoyed
this tournament
best friend but we're going to see all
year as far as competition so definitely
interesting to see how these guys
unfortunately there's not the world
championship this year we will have that
coming back next year so you're all for
that so we kind of have to look forward
to these big tournaments like the sink
failed Cup but everyone thanks for
watching the tournament and I'll see you
guys in the next one thanks for watching